last night the exclusive investigation
when you showed you two patents that
Google has filed for they show the
company's willingness to stick a camera
in your bedroom and spy on you and your
children then of course use it
information to sell you things that's
how surveillance capitalism works but
currently Google doesn't have a camera
in every bedroom or every home it does
have a phone in millions of people's
pockets though and the question is how
much information is Google getting from
those phones we put a couple of our
smartest producers on this and then we
send fox news headlines anchor Brett
Larson out to investigate watch we know
that Google is tracking us we agree to
it when we set up our phones so we
wanted to figure out what exactly Google
is learning about us throughout the day
so here's what we're gonna do we have
two identical phones the only difference
between these two phones is this one is
an airplane mode both of the phones lack
of SIM card and they haven't been set up
to access any Wi-Fi networks so for all
intents and purposes these phones have
no connection to a data network we're
gonna keep them with us throughout the
day and while I travel around DC we're
gonna figure out just what Google is
finding out about me our first stop Sims
convenience store just outside our Fox
Bureau for a quick coffee from there we
took a walk to the Capitol and took a
quick walk around the Senate office
buildings and then decided to hop in a
car and head around town hello we're
going to the Children's Hospital please
to run our tests we had to do more than
walk the block so we took a tour around
our nation's capitol first due north to
the Children's National Medical Center
hospital then west to st. Alban School
and the National Cathedral our tour
around town was a 14 mile journey that
lasted more than an hour the entire time
the phones had no access to the Internet
oh my goodness not a Wi-Fi connection
and not any cellular data service it
almost seemed quaint to assume that
Google wouldn't even be able to collect
data on me let's head back to the bureau
my friend
a church is beautiful Google's business
model is simple collect data on its
users and then use that data to sell
targeted ads it's a business model
called surveillance capitalism but does
that critical data collection work even
when your phones aren't connected so
we're back here at our Fox Bureau in DC
and we've got both of our phones exactly
how we left with them the only
difference really I snapped a couple of
bad selfies at the National Cathedral
but otherwise they have stayed in my
pocket for the entire day so let's find
out what they know this is our
man-in-the-middle device it's basically
a Wi-Fi network that these phones are
going to connect to once we turn their
Wi-Fi on it's going to pass data through
it on the way to Google but on the way
we're actually going to get a copy of
the same data that Google's going to get
we'll be able to decrypt it and then
find out where we've been throughout the
day within minutes the numbers rolled in
the phone that wasn't on airplane mode
registered more than 100 locations 130
activities and even 152 barometric
readings as soon as it hooked up to our
Wi-Fi it transmitted 300 kilobytes of
data straight to Google the phone even
logged our exact locations tracking us
all around town the capital the hospital
the school and the cathedral now you may
notice what's missing here is the exact
route that we took but it got that data
too it knows when I got out of the car
the metadata has a time log down to the
very second tracking everything when
they think that you're walking riding
and yes even getting out of the car okay
so you're thinking this isn't a big deal
I'll just put my phone in airplane mode
yeah we thought of that too this is the
other phone that we had with us that no
SIM card also remained in airplane mode
the entire time let's see what kind of
data it captured the phone with airplane
mode activated actually logged more
locations and activities than the other
phone and it also transferred hundreds
of kilobytes of data to Google as soon
as it was activated the only thing
that's missing from this map is our stop
at the Children's Hospital but it still
knows we were there there it is exiting
vehicle a hundred percent accuracy
through complicated user agreements and
free software Google gets users to sign
away their private
see for nothing they're even following
you in the places that most people would
expect total privacy government
buildings a Children's Hospital a
private school a church every move you
make every step you take google is
watching you now in a statement to Fox
News Google told us that users who want
to opt out of tracking should turn off
location history but doing that is
harder than you'd think and most of
googles apps include hitting queries
that automatically sign you up for the
surveillance for now we will continue
looking into how Silicon Valley sells
your privacy but until then just
remember when you're using a free online
service you're probably not the customer
you're actually the product sucker
shocking which airplane mode on they are
still following everything you do and
automatically updates yeah them well I
can't wait to find out what they do with
all that data but thank you for that it
was a great report thanks doctor